le point avant avant qu'on aborde une
idée de votre programme qui est
intéressante notamment pour les moins de
30 ans je voudrais avoir votre avis sur
la socio économie globale puisque ça va
effectivement impactés notamment
beaucoup le pouvoir d'achat on est dans
une situation qui va être quand même
complexe pour vous si vous êtes élu
demain vous avez une hausse de
l'inflation donc une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat d'ailleurs cela qui est très
importante l'insee prévoit une hausse de
l'inflation delà de 4 % c'est des
niveaux qui sont très élevés par rapport
à ce qu'on a connu on va voir bien sûr
une croissance économique qui va
ralentir une scène nous a déjà averti
encore aujourd'hui la croissance premier
trimestre va ralentir tout simplement
parce que klaus de l'inflation on a
moins de consommation et dans le même
temps vous avez aussi vous l'aviez
mentionné en introduction une dette qui
reste très importante donc en fait
comment vous allez réussir à réconcilier
un peu l'inconciliable parce qu'on a
trois objectifs qui sont divers est-ce
que 1 premièrement vous pensez
typiquement que les mesures prises par
le gouvernement comme indemnité
inflation peuvent être pertinentes sur
le long terme on sait que c'est efficace
à l'instant t mais c'est un coin élevé
pour l'état et deuxième point si on est
dans un scénario où l'inflation est
durablement plus élevé et je vous
rejoins notamment sur la transition
énergétique tous les experts économiques
on dise que c'est inflationnistes qu'est
ce que vous faites dans ce contexte là
est ce qu'on va continuellement mettre
en place ce type de mesure indemnités
inflation les pérenniser dans le temps
ou pas par exemple non d'abord il ya une
chose que je ferais par rapport à
l'inflation c'est la réindexation des
retraites parce que à un moment donné
année après année sur les pensions qui
sont contraintes ca les retraités
peuvent pas faire un petit boulot à côté
enfin pas tous pour pouvoir compléter
leur retraite donc il faut que l'air que
les pensions soient indexés sur
l'inflation moi j'ai deux objectifs
d'abord j'ai objectif de rendre leur
argent aux français c'est un de mes
slogan est je veux leur rendre je les
dis entre 150 à 200 euros par mois je
présenterai d'ici quelques jours
d'ailleurs l'intégralité des mesures qui
permettent de restituer en moyenne à
chaque ménage 150 à 220 euros mwh a
priori car oui si 150 à 200 euros en
bons d'achat parce qu'en réalité les
français leur priorité c'est pas que
l'immigration de l'insécurité les
intéresse pas il en souffre mais le
problème c'est que le pouvoir d'achat
c'est la fin du mois c'est la fin du
camp il se demande comment est-ce qu'ils
vont terminer eh bien je fais avec la
baisse de la tva sur les produits
énergétiques dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure je fais en créant une demi le
plein fiscale pour dell deuxième enfant
en reste et rétablissement de la demi
part pour les veufs et les veuves en
revalorisant les petites retraites en
exonérant d'impôt sur le revenu les
jeunes de moins de 30 ans on en parlera
par toutes ces mesures là eh bien ça
permet de rendre du pouvoir d'achat donc
ça permet de rendre aussi du pouvoir de
consommer d'accord ça c'est la première
des choses est la deuxième des choses
c'est quand il était je mets en place 1
comment dire une relance keynésienne sur
fonds privés par l'intermédiaire du
fonds souverain que je vais mettre en
oeuvre qui va permettre au français de
devenir actionnaires en fait de la
maison france qui est quand même dont
j'espère que îlots il atteindra 500
milliards à la fin du quinquennat parce
qu'il sera rémunéré évidemment à la
hauteur de l'inflation pour l'instant
c'est que pour cent mais on l'adaptera à
la menace expliqué ce qu'est le fonds
souverain marine le pen c'est quoi c'est
le joli il ya 2300 milliards faite de
d'epargne chez les français un peu plus
d'ailleurs été mais disons disponibles
2300 milliards je viens leur dire je
vais créer un fonds venaient me prêter
de l'argent dans ce fonds je vous
rémunère 2% par an c'est à dire plus
évidemment que le livret a est avec cet
argent je vais investir dans des
technologies d'avenir des entreprises en
fonds propres qui sont rentables
évidemment et ça va permettre en même
temps de rémunérer les français et en
même temps d'ailleurs de créer des
recettes pour l'état tout en accordant
des fonds propres aux entreprises mais
aussi en créant des infrastructures qui
sont nécessaires au développement de
notre pays voyez une sortie d'autoroute
nationaliser les autoroutes ou sorties
d'autoroutes et bien c'est l'ensemble
d'un territoire qui est revitaliser dans
lequel les entreprises peuvent
s'installer par exemple juste
christopher et demi on a entendu les
quelques propositions de marine le pen
est-ce que c'est faisable est-ce que
c'est réalisable ce que dit marine le
pen ou est-ce que c'est utopique alors
il y aura que certaines mesures qui sans
complexe typiquement sur le fond le
problème c'est que si on veut que les
français investissent il faut au delà de
l'inflation pour que soient plus
rémunérateurs donc à l'instant t c'est
au moins le livret a c'est en dessous de
l'inflation ben ça que ça m'intéresse
d'abord son argent sur les horaires
avant entre elles c'est un message qui
est envoyé mais il faudra au moins 4% et
le problème c'est si vous offrez ce
levier là bien évidemment pour les
français c'est un outil l'investissement
mais l'état sans d'être plus que ce
qu'il ne le ferait en temps normal sur
les marchés financiers mais non
puisqu'il est en réalité l'objectif
c'est que ce fonds il ils puissent
investir dans des activités qui sont à 6
ou 7 2 % de rentabilité c'est ça
l'objectif gers et de choisir aussi les
activités qui sont rentables or il y en
a beaucoup des activités en réalité qui
sont rentables y compris en matière
d'infrastructures si on n'investit que
le fonds souverain par exemple dans un
grand plan scanner irm mais c'est très
rentable sur le long terme moi j'ai bien
sûr c'est extrêmement rentable il ya
comme ça toute une série de domaines qui
touchent encore une fois à
l'organisation territoriale de notre
pays qui touche aux infrastructures qui
sont nécessaires pour
cet aménagement territorial qui tous
aussi aux investissements d'avenir aux
investissements technologiques d'avenir
et qui sont rentables juste on va
pouvoir revenir sur les mesures mesures
vous proposez aussi baisse de la tva sur
l'énergie de 20 à 5 5% là on en a parlé
tout à l'heure sur les carburants le
fioul le gaz l'électricité en tant que
biens de première nécessité juste
christopher des mythes pour que les
téléspectateurs comprennent bien ce que
programme économique de marine le pen
c'est important ce soit parce qu'il faut
vraiment il ya beaucoup de gens aussi
qu'ils disent est ce qu est ce qu
économiquement ça tient la route le
programme de marine le pen et le
rassemblement national est ce que c'est
possible de faire ça où est ce qu'on va
avoir un gros gros trou
alors à l'instant t sur du court terme
oui c'est toujours possible parce
qu'avec un budget on peut gérer sur du
court terme le problème c'est que toutes
ces mesures là s'ils doivent être
pérennisés dans le temps et c'est ma
crainte parce que comme je l'aï dit on
va voir l'inflation sur le long terme aa
oui souvent on veut pas on veut pas des
choses à court terme de ce long terme ça
reste très compliqué parce que comme je
les dis on va avoir une inflation qui
reste élevé peu de croissance provenant
beaucoup moins d'ailleurs que ce
qu'anticipe à l'heure actuelle le
gouvernement dont il ya eu un effet
d'optimisme donc un certain stade si on
baisse les rentrées fiscales
automatiquement ça déséquilibre le
budget donc il faudra faire un choix
soit effectivement vous légitimement
vous accentuée sur le pouvoir d'achat et
vous laisserez déraper temporairement
les déficits au moins sur le mandat en
espérant que la croissance soit là donc
c'est vrai qu'il faudra faire un choix
entre les différents arbitral moi je
crois pas parce que à côté je fais des
économies suffisamment il se l'est dit
les piranhas chaque jour on en français
je ne vais pas créer d'impôt
supplémentaire je ne vais pas de créer
de dette supplémentaire c'est à dire que
à côté et quand je présenterai mon
budget clairement il sera en équilibre à
côté il y aura des économies il y aura
18 milliards d'économies par an sur
l'immigration les choses ont été faites
de manière extrêmement précise chiffres
et de manière extrêmement précise il y
aura 15 milliards j'ai pris la
fourchette basse de sur la fraude
d'ailleurs je suis étonné parce que j'ai
vu que charles prat soutient valérie
pécresse et qu' il parle de 45 milliards
et pourtant valérie pécresse se fonde
sur 15 milliards comme moi pour les
bénéfices de la lutte contre la fraude
alors pour moi les mêmes créé voulait
créer un ministère de lutte contre la
fraude ah oui contre les fraudes outre
les fresques on parle souvent de la
fraude en parlant de la fraude sociale
bon évidemment il y à de la fraude
sociale de la fraude aux cotisations il
ya de la faute aux prestations mais à
beaucoup d'autres fraudes il ya de la
fois des importations alimentaires par
exemple il ya de la fraude aux
productions industrielles qui sont
importés dans notre pays sans respecter
les normes qui sont imposés à nos
industriels et tout ça ça crée de la
concurrence déloyale et la concurrence
déloyale elle entraîne des pertes de
marché donc c'est très importante pour
lutter contre ça lutter contre les
ententes vous savez les grands groupes
souvent font entre eux des ententes
c'est à dire qu'il décide que ils se
décident ils se mettre d'accord sur un
prix comme ça au lieu que la concurrence
joue et que le prix baisse et bien ils
maintiennent un prix quéau mais à chaque
fois ils se font attraper le problème
c'est que les sanctions qui sont
prononcées sont dérisoires par rapport
aux bénéfices qu'ils ont retiré de la
fraude donc là aussi il faut que les
français arrêtent d'être volée comme au
coin d'un bois vous voulez aussi
récupérer des sous en réduisant la
contribution à une europe et à 8,9
milliards enfin je versais objectivement
c'est beaucoup déjà je rappelle et je
sais plus qui a dit ça des fois je crois
que c'est jean lassalle et il a
parfaitement raison ou jean luc
mélenchon je me suis appuyé il dit on
déjà en offre à l'europe la dissuasion
nucléaire c'est quand même pas rien
surtout quand l'allemagne vient nous
expliquer la au bénéfice de la guerre
ans en ukraine qu'en fait ils ont zéro
armée banon n'a rien nous avons pas
d'accord donc en fait c'est nous c'est
notre armée qui allons au mali pour
défendre l'europe face aux groupes armés
terroristes c'est nous qui avons la
dissuasion nucléaire et l'air de rien ça
coûte de l'argent et en plus on a une
contribution qui ne cesse d'augmenter au
fur et à mesure net c'est-à-dire la
différence entre ce qu'on paie est ce
qu'on reçoit donc je voudrais que ça
revienne pourquoi au montant à peu près
de 2002 2004 c'est-à-dire deux milliards
et demi ça me paraît raisonnable et donc
là vous récupérez 7 milliards donc là ce
qui vous fait en fait une récupération
de 40 milliards ah oui ben rien que ça
voyez or la baisse de la tva c'est 12
milliards je vous laisse y gérer mon
budget et ça continue
est ce que c'est parce qu'il sait ce que
c'est possible ça avec des négociations
sur l'union européenne donc ça nécessite
du temps et après tout ce qui est
mesures de lutte contre les fraudes qui
sont effectivement toujours peut-être
est nécessaire le problème c'est que la
question c'est toujours de l'efficacité
et on sait très bien que objectivement
les programmes par rapport à ce qui est
présenté est ce qu'on est en mesure de
faire à l'instant t sans compter
éventuellement dégradation économique
etc qui est un grand décalage si vous
êtes confronté à une situation vous fait
quel choix c'est à dire 'est-ce que vous
laisser temporairement couvrir la dette
en vous disant que dans tous les cas les
autres feront la même situation en
europe parce que c'est vrai qu'on est
dans une question importante à ce niveau
ou est ce que vous allez dire ce sera le
pouvoir d'achat la priorité est en tout
cas je mettre en place les mesures de
telle augmentation des impôts je pense
que le pouvoir d'achat est absolument
une priorité aujourd'hui les français
sont étranglées donc évidemment on peut
toujours prévoir des catastrophes qui
pourraient arriver et c est bien s'il
arrive une catastrophe mon choix ce sera
la préservation du pouvoir d'achat des
français et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai été un peu sévère avec ce
qui assez comment dire avec assez de
nonchalance explique qu'il faut couper
l'importation de gaz russe et c'est sans
dire aux français que si on coupe cette
importation de gaz ça va multiplier par
8 leur facture de gaz et puis par six
leur facture d'électricité
il faut dire aux français cela et moi je
viens leur dire moi je fais le choix de
vous protéger je fais le choix de
protéger votre pouvoir d'achat parce que
je sais très bien que la situation est
de plus en plus compliqué de plus en
plus difficile j'ai été amené à prendre
d'ailleurs pas mal de mesures pour les
français les plus vulnérables par
exemple pour les familles monoparentales
un quart des familles quand même un
l'air de rien eh bien j'ai doublé l'aide
qui leur est apportée par ce que je
trouve que 103 euros par enfant je suis
là mettez moi de vous dire quand on est
une famille monoparentale c'est pas très
facile vous les ressources et les
doubles et où les relances et aussi la
natalité française proposait une part
fiscale complète dès le deuxième est
notre grand truc c'est votre projet
économique tout pour et tpe les pme oui
voilà et et notamment la la la la
surface dans le cadre des impôts de 2,2
production que je supprime jeu j'ai
supprimé la cfe parce que c'est la cfe
qui particulièrement frappe l'été c'est
utile m c'est quoi votre position pour
la re dire aux français sur
lies fgtb qualité mais qui remplaçait
par l'ifi maintenant bien moi je vais
supprimer les filles parce que l'ifi
c'est un impôt sur l'or sur
l'enracinement c'est un impôt sur
l'investissement immobilier en fait donc
en fait emmanuel macron il a dit bon je
ne taxe plus la spéculation en revanche
je vais taxes et l'enracinement bon ben
moi je fais exactement l'inversé je ne
taxant vous d ali fille normale non je
reviens à un appât dsf normalement
bonaly ses plans je reviens un impôt sur
la fortune financière sesf l inverse des
manuels macron je ne ne taxe plus en
tout cas j'ai xonar la résidence
principale ou unique parce que parfois
on a une résidence unique mais on habite
pas eh bien elle sera également
exonérées de l'impôt sur la fortune
financière en revanche évidemment les
les biens professionnels
tout ça ce sera exonérée en revanche est
bien je je je taxe la fortune financière
voilà et vous rétablissez il y un lit sf
pme qui permettait justement de
favoriser l'investissement dans les pme
qui avait été supprimé et qui avait été
quand même critiqué lorsqu'il a été
supprimé oui moi je trouve que c'est je
trouve que c'est très bien de pouvoir
permettre l'investissement dans les pme
même s'ils m'ont fonds souverains et
aussi
là pour ça